[Applause]
is a good sign yes
are you nervous i'm [ __ ] myself
[ __ ] yourself so am i you know i do
every time yeah before service okay good
luck concentrate
wake up and i want to hear you a little
bit yes yes tonight's starter is a salad
of roasted sea scallops with a
cauliflower puree and a caper raisin
dressing
turn them now back on the heat every
time you take that pan off what's
happening losing
losing the heat they're going to boil it
come on my two commas is weaker and bass
who's 24.
he was born in iraq grew up in london
and worked in a french restaurant i
don't want you to be moody or stop i
wanted to be concentrated what you're
doing nothing more than that yeah
and try and keep your nose out the way
and tamar who's just 18 years of age
tama's been working in his dad's kosher
restaurant since he was 11.
now you're not the smallest of cooks so
you're in danger of being clumsy so on
your toes like a ballerina
yes at the end of the day one will go
home and the other will come back to
compete for a job in my kitchen
can they stand the heat i'll order six
covers table eleven
six cellar sea scallops main course six
beef wellington on crude yes
didn't hear you tama yes sure that's
better thank you how many stops per
portion
uh three years so six pieces that's
right six threes are
six threes 18. too late wake up
always try to buy scallops that are
actually in their shell because it's a
great guarantee to how fresh they are
now to open up the scallop it's quite
easy you get your knife and you
push that through that tiny little gap
and just twist
and once you've opened the shell get the
top of the knife and just slide
against the top of the shelf and look
what happens the shell comes up
there you go now the only piece of the
skull that we're interested in
is this white part here slide your thumb
down the muscle
and pop it out of its skirt this orange
beak
the coral is called i don't really like
cooking with them because they taste of
nothing and they get very rubbery
it's not worth it get rid of the orange
part and just cook that nice white
pearl the easiest way to cut the skull
up in half is look at this flat bit here
and then just find out halfway and what
that does is if you're halfway there it
cuts the scallop
exactly into half look how fresh they
are they're still moving
they're still pulsating that's the only
way to eat scallops
open up in your hand like that yeah
and then in the seasoning here we've got
half curry powder
half salt and when you season always
season from a height so it spreads
across it yeah
okay let's go four scallops into the pan
scallops in 12 o'clock that's it there
you go by the time we get down to six
o'clock
we know exactly where to turn the skull
okay
off the heat watch and turn yes look how
fresh these scallops are let's go
and less olive oil in there next time
yeah what are you doing now tam is
you're actually boiling the scallop as
opposed to salting it okay
yeah yeah back on the heat come on
you're losing the heat in the pan
right stop stop stop stop tell me the
difference between no scallops no
scallops
come on then i want to start again get
them in the bin and start again
i can't serve two portions nicely done
and two portions have been boiled
now turn around and work together yes
take your time
i'm serving the scallops on a delicious
cauliflower puree
now cook them butter for about two to
three minutes until they go nice and
soft and then
we're gonna add some milk and what the
milk does it actually helps keep the
puree really nice and vibrant white
now as that milk starts to boil we're to
finish it with a touch of cream
and now we're going to cook that
outbound in another three or four
minutes and then
puree it's really important to blend
this when it's really nice and hot so
therefore the hotter it is the finer it
becomes if you leave it to cool down
then you'll get lumps through it so make
sure
that you always blend it when it's hot
okay now look what's inside this really
nice rich
creamy smooth cauliflower puree
that will beat cauliflower and cheese
any day
how many stones you've got per portion
six per portion okay good watch
watch me cauliflower puree on then the
caper raisin vinaigrette watch
it's very strong yeah it's very tasty
very tangy
now we get the sweetness of the scallops
on there on top of the cauliflower puree
presentation is crucial the less
elements in a dish the more important it
is to plate it upright
right stop stop there okay you're not
listening to me
you're going around the outside of the
plate again yeah there you put them on
the scallops sit on top of the cloud
puree let's start again
yeah third time lucky i want you to
really think about how much money you're
wasting
and i want you seriously to wake up and
get a grip this is the same table
we're doing for the third time yes yes
chef this doesn't go out properly
what are you going home don't worry
about waiting till later oil in the pan
let's go
dear oh dear just drizzle that round
there like that
now look at yours look at mine tell me
the difference
you've gone out around the rim of the
plate customers don't want to eat off
the rim of the plate you come in
next time get it right okay clean the
plate let's go
[Applause]
it was amazing we spent the first two
minutes trying to figure out what all
the different flavors were
and having various guesses um we
actually guessed mashed potato
without the cauliflower but the over
overwhelming flavor was the capers
um and the sweetness in that it just
complemented the scallops it was
fantastic
the cauliflower puree is lovely i've
never thought of pureeing cauliflower
before but
it really works really well with the
scopes it's very nice
ladies good to see you how are you i'm
good how are you good
you enjoyed your scholarship yeah they
were lovely but they're not quite my
palettes just you don't like scallops
yeah i mean it's not my palettes
really where have the coral's gone you
know every time i see a restaurant
serving coals of scallops i get out
because of the cheapskate identification
they taste
very oh i love them they're so rich
they're so creamy i want the corals give
me the corn i don't know what she's
talking about i think
more importantly they take twice as long
to cook than they do with the white meat
and by time the
coral's cooked the scarf's overcooked so
ladies what do you look for when you
walk into a restaurant i mean
hygiene-wise well
everything i don't like cutlery that's
been taken that's all got
watermark i can't stand it okay
everything's going and i can't stand
stem glass they've been stored and
there's always dust here i can't stand
that
and clean loose kimchi balloon yeah come
on i do because these always let
restaurants down
um now gordon dear yes you know you may
be a a famous chef
but you've got to inspect the lose dear
[Music]
i can't believe you put your head down
there get in there i'm not going to put
my head
in that get in there what's it like
yeah there you go i mean it looks quite
clean it actually smells quite clean
that's clean you got it yes yeah
that one nice there's only pee-pee on
the seats how can you
spot pee-pee underneath because you turn
sideways to shine it's all pee-pee
stains
you're doing a good job here okay door
hand tuna i've got to say i'm i'm highly
impressed you're happy with the toilets
they're clean are you rushing me out of
here are we going to go back to the
dining room
guess what get out doing your favor
you haven't washed your hands you've
come out the toilet and you haven't
washed your hands
excuse me i've not come out yet dear
next on the menu along with the main
course of beef wellington
i don't believe it richard wilson's in
the house
jonathan ross paid me ten thousand
pounds to say i'm sorry
okay okay new potatoes in first we'll
start salting do not forget to take out
the garlic yes sure welcome back to the
f-word next up our main course a real
classic fillet of beef wellington
with sauteed potatoes and wilted baby
gem lettuce
b fill it lean meat with little fine
sinews of fat running through
it just melts in your mouth like butter
season
[Applause]
hot pan olive oil
seal
mustard think about it
fill it beef wellington english mustard
you're not gonna put dijon there are you
[Music]
mushrooms
season blitz
now i've got to take the water out the
mushrooms look how wet they are
we don't put oil or butter into the pan
we put nothing in there
look how much water is coming out now
assemble
cling film palmer ham
mushrooms beef center
and roll
twist it nice and tight chill 20 minutes
puff pastry
beef unwrap on
to the pastry egg wash
don't skimp on the egg wash now because
we really need it to stick
[Music]
tuck that in chill five minutes
delays
[Music]
score
rock salt
[Applause]
bake
[Applause]
[Music]
the most important thing about filler
beef wellington do not slice it thinly
okay
turn it around and slice it about an
inch thick
beef wellington done
that lettuce goes in at the last minute
okay let it just taste
literally 20 seconds to wilt nice hot
pan
don't get too oily now with the beef
wellington we're serving sauteed
potatoes and wilted baby gem lettuce
now if you've never eaten cooked lettuce
before you have to try because it is
absolutely delicious hot pan
olive oil and these are the outside
leaves of the baby gem the nice big
thick robust leaves so into the pan
and quickly soda them
out beautiful
now saturday new potatoes these are part
boils that have been boiled for about
four and a half five minutes
and then we leave the skins on and just
cut them in half
and we part ball them a to soften them
and b
so they actually stay nice and whole
and then get some garlic and some thyme
and what we do with the garlic is we
just get the clover garlic
we don't need to peel it we just get a
clove like that
on the board and just crush
so that sort of crushes oozes the center
of the garlic into the potatoes
and then perfumes them
and great for flavor and then into the
pan
again nice hot pan
now to get some really nice color on the
potatoes and then 30 seconds before the
potatoes come out of the pan
just a little knob of butter from there
so gives that really nice golden brown
color on the potato
now christmas is almost here and my
turkey's time is running out
i'm trying to grow my own christmas
dinner and hugh early witting still is
the main man when it comes to small
holdings
hello mate are you well very well good
to see you santa's come early
well i'll say yes what's in there the
presents are not for you and they're not
even for the kids
no they're for the birds he's brought
the ingredients for his own recipe
turkey feed special christmas treat so
what's in there exactly
okay let's have a look the main mix that
i think you should get them on for the
last two weeks
is whole grain barley some walnuts
fantastic
so we got barley we got barley whole
barley grains
and oats and walnuts and walnuts now
that is an
old uh turkey rivers trick just the
natural oils in that just give them a
little bit of a boost
amazing so we're almost feeding them
their perfect sort of christmas lunch
send off and aren't we yeah
yeah we're giving them the best possible
christmas dinner so that you can have
the best possible christmas dinner
fascinating what you're going to do with
the apples i'll bring them out yeah
we'll have a play with them a bit later
on let's go with this first
excellent what do you think the space
this is a good space
you could do a lot here you could go
beyond the turkeys for sure
you've just about got enough space here
for a pair of pigs
maybe an idea for next year but i mean
i'll let you break that one to the
misses you know that
okay let's see if they're at all
interested in my special mix
how about that straight away they seem
to like it straight away
i think they could just have a little
bit more
stimulation while they're out on the
lawn you've got a croquet set have you
okay here we go now lovely set gordon
yeah amazing
it hasn't hasn't seen a lot of views no
it hasn't seen it it's the first time
hugh thinks that pecking apples hanging
from croquet hoops will relax the
turkeys
and the relaxed bird is a tasty bird
so when my friend asked me that croquet
said oh you used it yet i got you for
your birthday
i've got a great idea for him now so yes
it's been put to bloody good use
even the river cottage birds don't get
this sort of treat
fantastic if these turkeys start pecking
the apples
i'll be very excited but it looks like
the turkeys don't want to play the game
[Music]
the slight problem with nigella and
dealer they're obviously guys now look
at the weight and the size
that must have come as a surprise yeah
that was a big surprise what do you
reckon i mean
change their names or kind of put delia
as the new hue or nigel for
nigella gordon i don't know i mean it's
very flattering but
i'd like to talk to you a little bit
about this whole name thing it's
possible
that you made a little bit of a mistake
naming them ready
possible because it's that much easier
to form a sentimental attachment to a
creature if you give it a name
it's actually quite interesting when you
see how attached the kids have become
my oldest oscar he's never had a problem
with that until
last year one of our cows gave birth
of course the calf was a pretty little
black and white calf oscar christened it
lovely and we had lovely and lovely had
a name and oscar who for a couple of
years had been
very calm and understanding about the
whole grow it eat it thing
suddenly he had a named animal that he
had a personal relationship
and then it that for the first time we
had problems you've got to start saying
to them
which is looking the tastiest which
one's going on first which is going in
the oven first which bits do you like
do you like the leg or the wing or will
you you know that sort of thing yeah
how are we going to cook them taking
something to slaughter is an emotional
occasion yeah
you can't sort of totally put that out
the way no you've just got to work
through it
for me the way to work through it is to
think these creatures have lived very
well i've
done the best i can for them yeah
absolutely and the big question of
course next autumn will be you know
daddy we're going to get some more
turkeys for christmas that's what i want
to hear
yeah yeah that is what you want to hear
or pigs for spring pigs for easter
chickens and pigs for easter turkeys for
christmas i can lend you a cow
you can get up every morning and do some
milking
i might just fit it in over here damn
the thing is though once you start
rearing your own livestock
it's so lovely you just won't want to
stop yeah and you'll want to try
something different and keep moving on
and before you know it gordon this whole
place is just going to be
it's going to be a little farm it's
going to be great sugar
let's go four now yes let's go big boy
all right stop so what have you done to
that so uh the
flames caught on yeah well okay yeah if
his corn is burnt get rid of it yeah of
course you do some more
wake up come on we go to all this extent
we make these amazing wellingtons
and the pan's too hot yeah of course
we're gonna do some more
okay let's go
first slice come on
watch look there in second slice
now look at the beef it's absolutely
perfectly cooked because they've rested
beautifully okay
yeah nice and pink in the center okay
and we all just want to season that
lightly with a bit of rock salt okay
let's go
now the presentation is really important
you know that we're going to start off
with the letters at the top of the plate
at 12 o'clock
at nine o'clock we've got the vegetables
and then at six o'clock with this lovely
slice
of wellington now this is a classic
vinaigrette that's been thickened
with mustard i'm just gonna drizzle the
warm vinaigrette
over the salad and the sauteed potatoes
now what would those customers be
thinking if you sent all that bitter
burnt lettuce they'd be pissed off yeah
because they'll be pissed off
because i would be as well good well
don't send it then let's go clean the
plates good boy
up a bass come on you can help out nice
not on the rim not on the rim there
first three four tables went out lovely
this stays like that yes
good master vinaigrette good boy let's
go and take the garlic out let's go
inside the lettuce and just a little bit
over the potatoes come on trey's out
come on
work with me please you're standing
gorping at me like you're an art
exhibition wake up
go i look beautiful right you made a
mistake like that
yeah i don't want to see you sucking
there like something big you know i want
you to come back
come back then your face let's go wakey
richard how are you i'm very welcome god
how are you doing i'm verondi thank you
good to see you how was your main course
very very good you enjoyed it i never
had cooked lettuce before really
yeah now do you actually cook at home i
do yes
and what kind of sort of food you cook
oh simple
fish in the oven uh potatoes being
scottish yes
i have two potatoes with everything but
if you sent me to a desert island
and said what could you eat i'd probably
have to say potatoes
i hear behind the scenes you're slightly
intimidated about confronting waiters
when you go to a restaurant
i remember the first restaurant i
actually complained in the tomato the
grilled tomato was
black and i i choked in my mouth and
as i said it and i said look i'm i'm
sorry but this
this tomato was uneatable yeah did you
say was it love
and that was it that was it well it's
really interesting listen to you saying
that you're sort of
uncomfortable with complaining when the
character you played for so many years
was a constant pain in the ass well
victor meldru wouldn't know his way
around a good restaurant unfortunately
whenever you want to complain to it
becomes a bit of a confusion because
there's so many waiters
always complain to the mater d or the
manager yeah now
i've got a bit of a food quiz tongue
twister yeah which part of a sheep's
head is an arabic food delicacy
the eyes what round sugary thing with a
hole in the middle
does homer simpson love to eat a
doughnut
a doughnut it's exactly that well done
no i do love doughnuts
my mother made a good donut i love
donuts one insect makes honey
a bee a bee fantastic if you follow up
yeah what'd you do with your food
that's left on the plate put it in the
bin no you
leak what you need you leave it you
leave it
exactly you've got them all right well
done i
good
me eat
well done jonathan ross spent me ten
thousand pounds to see
i'm sorry i'll pay you 10 pounds here
now richard you're an absolute star
thank you so much it's an absolute
pleasure best wishes thank you cheers
i don't believe it i can't believe you
said it i really like my meat bloody
great i like it really
really rare
whenever i go to restaurants it's never
quite rare enough
so this was really good for me beef
wellington was absolutely superb i mean
it really was the meat was fantastic
melting them out
and the mustard in the beef wellington
was a rare touch really nice
i don't even normally eat red meat but
it really surprised me because it was so
light
and it was so easy to cut and it was it
was it was easy on your palate and it
kind of went down really easily i
usually
want to eat red meat it was like quite
tough or something like that but this
time it was
it was really delicious and the whole
thing was great good to see you
did you enjoy your beef wellington yes
yeah could you try cooking that at home
we were just talking about that yeah
definitely yeah the wellington in
particular is great for a large party
whether it's six of you or eighty or
even ten of you
one nice whole phillips scared
wellington though because i always kind
of think to myself
how do you get the pastry crisp on the
outside when you don't cook it for very
long
that work that's a good question first
of all when you start cooking the
wellington you start cooking at 200
degrees
and you cook it at 200 degrees for about
8 to 10 minutes so it gets color
right and then you turn it down to 180
and cook for about a further 20 minutes
so it gets really nice and crispy to
coin a phrase from colin farrell it was
a bleeding delish
but uh no as a meal in the hole it was
absolutely beautiful the
cut of beef was just tender delicious
the mushrooms loved that and the lettuce
was uh different but uh
loved it as well next on the menu how
clean is my kitchen
i can't believe the mess look at the
state of it
how clean is your hair wait till you see
the mess i make of you dear later
i cook some real fast food just a smell
quicker than a microwave meal and giles
debunks detox does detox actually mean
anything
welcome back to the f-word now next up
is pudding where kim and aggie from how
kings your house are actually going to
try and attempt to beat me with their
recipe
for a trifle
ladies can we get going nice clean hands
now don't get nervous because i'm here
you're missing joey start getting
twisted you can i affect men like that
you know
yeah now i'm doing a bit of a sort of a
straightforward classic trifle
and we're doing a trifle with
caramelised peaches and clementine very
festive
done with the most amazing customers
made with vanilla and then a nice twist
at the end
we want to get some salty peanuts and
turn them into a caramel salted peanut
aggie tell me what you're doing okay i'm
uh i'm beating up my egg yolks and the
sugar and vanilla case
i'm going to put a wee bit of corn flour
in because i'm slightly nervous that it
it'll split i don't want that to happen
okay and i've also can i just say i've
made my own trifle sponges that's
amazing
with goose eggs that i bought from the
front that's fantastic you may as well
go home
oh dear i don't know we could have
bloody well win this we have still got
to win this so for my trip i'm going to
make um
the most amazing custard but very simple
custard not like kim and agus this is
sort of done with
sugar eggs and fresh vanilla pods do you
know what i've used the wrong
cream i love you already you swear like
a chef
if aggie wins he's going to cry like a
baby i sense that you know i'm glad
you're determined to end
up i'm afraid i'm very competitive
now what's the most important tip you
could give to anyone out there about
keeping their kitchen at home clean what
would you say first
your um wiping up cloth absolutely clean
stop spreading the bacteria and clean as
you go
absolutely clean as you go that's right
clean as you go and get everyone else to
muck in
so the peaches we're just gonna quarter
roast them off in a little bit of sugar
the exciting thing about caramelizing
these peaches is then with the most
amazing sugar
very fragrant muscovado sugar and that
gives a really nice sort of rich syrupy
color
onto the peaches
will you stop there for goodness man's a
big man you know
i did i feel like we are coming back in
the kitchen
here do you need to take off these love
hands are growing a bit
why do i don't mind hanging out
wow [ __ ] i feel like i've got a baby
rhino on my back putting him off his
food for god's sake
if they're trying to distract me it
really is working you know that because
i can't can't just concentrate on
anything right now
god i've never had a 64 year old grab my
boobs like that and now i'm giving the
swiss roll a little bit of a sort of um
bit of a scottish effect i'm sort of
dousing it in grand marnier
uh can i just say i can't believe the
mess
look at the state of this how clean is
your house where do you see the mess i
make of you dear ladies
look at the floor celebrities i've
roasted the peach and the clementine off
in
muscovado sugar they've sort of um been
caramelized beefy colored and now i'm
just going to add them to the sponge
and then we're going to add
the custard
my brain set but the custard's about to
set so i'm gonna put that in the fridge
to cool down and once that's nice and
cool we're gonna finish it with a creme
fraiche
finished with mustard sugar and
hopefully get rid of that honey monster
i'm finishing my trifle off with some
salted caramel peanuts
it's just salted peanuts in a pan
a sprinkle of sugar and a sprinkle of
salt but this is not any salt this is
not a powder salt this is called
seldagan
it's a sort of rare gray sea salt very
powerful
very delicious and it goes well when you
make a caramel
i just leave them to cool down rolling
pin break them up and sprinkle on top of
your trifle
custard on top now most importantly get
it in the fridge and let it set for
about 35-40 minutes
now i've been in another woman's kitchen
this week and like so many women i've
met she reckons she hasn't got time to
cook
i'm so busy because i run my own theater
school hence why i never have time to
cook i'd really like to learn to cook
something that's
fast obviously it doesn't take too too
much preparation time something that's
quick something healthy
something that's not too complicated
which will get my confidence off of it
i think it's really important to be able
to cook especially when i've got a
husband and a little baby
and to eat it all up i'm very
embarrassed that i can't actually
okay now why can't you cook
a few reasons really mostly because my
mum can't cook really so you blaming her
i'm totally blaming her yeah but you
must be able to do absolutely
these well the simple things surely i
can do toast toast
ready break ready bro cool dear dear my
solution
is a fast food fix but real fast food
pasta fresh taco telly um something that
is not too complicated and we could use
dried uh linguine or spaghetti but this
is a fresh taco telly
the secret is of course cooking the
pasta very very simply
boiling water salty boiling water touch
of olive oil in there and you can mix
all these things in there things like um
marinated artichoke hearts um and you
know
olives smoked um pancetta great for
pasta dishes
easy to fry really full of flavor these
general things should be in your store
cupboard you know that
i'm going to teach rachel a simple pasta
dish that she can cook in 10 minutes
flat
i'll use some fresh crab some fresh
chili some lemon juice some parsley
through there and just mix it up that's
all it is
the hardest thing of course is just
cooking the pasta yeah apart from that
everything else is self-explanatory
first thing you do is put on a pan of
water put the water in it's not really
good
so take the pot from the kettle no
no dude the lights are on but rachel's
gone home
okay chopping board on here please yeah
where's the last time you chopped the
chili
yeah never never good okay get the
chilli you just rub it together like
that
okay and what that does it loosens all
the little seeds in the center right
once you've taken the top off slide down
the center like that right okay
and then just open it up with your
fingers look just push
all the way down and what that does it
gets rid of the seeds and the seeds are
actually hotter than the chili
that's what worries me about chilies
yeah well i'm just stinging my eyes
yeah yeah the most important thing now
is of course by the time you finish
chopping it
okay just wash your hands very very
quickly you get the chili just take nice
small slices there
three ingredients so far pasta crab and
chili
now just need some parsley yeah and it's
flat leaf parsley so it helps us cut
down the strength of chili and just make
it a lot more flavoursome
water's coming out to the boil nice
handful of pasta yeah
into the water please so that's the
other thing i never know how much pasta
to cook with the bowl that you're gonna
serve in
you get your bowl yeah okay and you look
there okay
now that looks a nice portion yeah yeah
so a spoonful of cheese in there
yep good
crab meat in good excellent
you're standing away from the stove and
you look like you're really nervous and
scared about that get close to it
yeah no you've got to get close to it
okay and you look like you're in control
of it yes okay yeah
how can you handle 320 kids and you
can't handle one little friend scared of
the fat
no no it's cooking that's called cooking
and i want you to squeeze some fresh
lemon juice in there fresh parsley over
there
okay nice so lift up one strand and we
want what we're looking for
is a bit of a bite in there that's quite
firm
just just about right into your pasta
now it's really important to get all
that crab meat mixed into it now
mix that up okay but look you're not
doing it well
get the spoon in there again i want you
to mix all that in there like that
okay all of it in there together yeah
quicker than a microwave meal
um without a doubt yeah two really nice
bowls
just a smell yeah it's gorgeous
so that's a meal for two in less than 10
[Music]
minutes
i'm impressed i can't believe you've
done this
no you did it you did it all well not
too much help
a little bit of help from the boss right
james happy
very happy yes really nice really nice
don't need to be scared of something
stick to something really really simple
yeah and just climb the ladder with it
yeah
we use crab yeah next time maybe prawns
next time roughly buying tomatoes and
you know
just maybe think about it during the day
and pick up the stuff on the way
yeah yeah no excuses
thank you do not stop yes and stay in
there madam
thank you thank you
okay excited i'm so nervous let's just
put them side by side i always like to
see them before you start serving them
yeah
like have a quick look underneath yeah
lots of jam too much jam actually
sponge and um looks a lot of a lot of
alcohol shaking down the bottom there
could just say good luck first because i
think you'll need it okay
okay well i wish i'd got frozen
raspberries because these fresh ones
have got no flavor whatsoever
yeah what do we expect you don't be
licking your fingers
oh is that all oh you stuck it in there
oh god isn't that awful
okay jean-baptiste yeah i've got to
serve my first because these ladies are
messing around again we are not missing
one's trying to grab my bollocks because
the one's trying to pickle it
we're there now might have a little
taste while we're in fact have you got a
straw
don't be funny don't be funny here's
ours
oh stop it's so alcoholic
oh god that is very good i just need a
little bit more i needed a little bit
more time cooking the peaches
that is very good that's beautiful oh
god that is so good i'm really happy you
like it you know
this week's tasters i'll try my dessert
first
i must admit i quite like the
composition i like the colors
i like it because there's good balancer
between the salt and
so sweet is it number two now thank you
it's very this one it's sloppy it's
delicious
i find it too sweet for me julia did you
do this do you prefer this at number one
number two i think i would definitely go
for the second one i'm gonna go for
number one
the number two is definitely the best
let's get the froggy where is it
jean-baptiste who play put these two
ladies at the misery yeah and tell me
who's the winner of course who's the
winner the winner is this week
yes kim and haggy oh get out
no you're joking aren't you
so much better oh god who's tasting them
up there
yes indeed they've got crap yeah i
should get i suggest i suggest we get
their mouths cleaned out are you sure
listen oh piss-off
oh my god i'm so sorry because yours is
so much better actually it really is
so much
oh dear those two women you know they're
absolutely obsessed with cleaning
they do seem to be no they're just mad i
mean nearly as mad as you are with your
organic food
i'm not especially mad they they are mad
if if cleanliness is next to godliness
you have been cooking there against the
pope and the archbishop of canterbury
now you've been finding out about sort
of cleaning out your insides right
well theoretically cleaning out your
insides it's a big boom thing this
detoxing
every year every year more and more
people getting into this thing it's a
kind of puritanical guilt thing they've
been drinking they've been smoking
they've been eating fatty foods fast
food
and they think you know they can't
change their lifestyle because so they
are what can i do
buy a little pot of something or some
pills or go on a regime
drinking booze smoking eating fast food
and all the other things you do on a
night out all the other things you do in
party season
have a downside they make you feel
terrible in the morning because you're
filling your body with
toxins now you can either lay off the
fun stuff altogether which doesn't sound
like fun
or you can look at detoxing there's a
whole industry devoted to it all sorts
of products all sorts of ideas
but do any of them work to find out i
suppose i'll have to get
toxic
what about what about the detox products
you can buy in the shops have you ever
tried one of them yes
have you really yeah what kind of a
product just a three-day detox
really yeah why did you try it you were
feeling terrible or something
no i think as a woman
really and did you lose weight i think
they're an absolute waste of time
but you gain energy and you gain you
gain yeah you gain stuff it's
a great thing
[Applause]
eat drink and be merry for tomorrow we
detox
it's the morning after the night before
as it so often is uh and i happen to
have four or five days in front of me
when i don't have to eat and drink and
do terrible toxic things and this would
be a good time for me to
detox i don't really have time all the
inclination to live on cabbage soup and
citrus fruit and water for the rest of
my life fortunately there is a range of
products on the market which claim to be
able to
detox me in three to five days but with
so many things to choose from how on
earth am i supposed to know which one is
the best
someone who might be able to tell me is
catherine collins chief dietitian at st
george's hospital
she points out that some detox products
include laxatives which will help
cleanse your body
in the way it knows best in your poo
that makes you feel like you've cleansed
your body so anyway
well absolutely but these things are you
know sexing up your poo a little bit
aren't they
and then so this is basically sexy poo
rather than it is because you've paid a
lot for it
does detox actually mean anything it's
the buzzword of the health industry
these does it mean anything
it means nothing at all it's a marketing
term not not a medical term at all
our bodies are treating the chemicals
that we get from diet from inhale
inhaling fumes from our stressful
lifestyles the things we produce
our bodies are dealing with that if they
didn't we'd be in hospital we'd be dead
you're buying an expensive adjunct to a
normal diet
and these sort of products wouldn't make
a rubbish diet good
there's no law defining what a detox
product is
so it's perfectly legal to put the word
on any product without having to prove
it's true
boots has become one of the uk's biggest
retailers of detox products since it
introduced them three years ago in
january after the party season
their sales shoot up by 40 percent how
does the detox work how do they do that
how do they knock out they don't detox
they support your body to do what it
it can do with its owners but they help
you
you maximize that potential it does have
some information here
about the essentials when detoxing and
obviously tells you what all the key
ingredients are vitamin c vitamin e
yes which you but you i mean that's the
they're vitamin supplements that people
might be taking anyway
potentially yes i suppose glutathione is
not one that you would traditionally
find
that's and what is glutathione it's um
it's a really powerful antioxidant
that's naturally stored in the liver
right and the liver is one of the main
organs in the body for detoxing
if it's stored naturally why do i need
more um again you may not be getting
adequate from your diet
because there are those who would say in
the kind of in the conventional medical
industry that the whole whole notion of
detox is
is just a sort of myth there are
different points of view admit that
but i think it comes back to the way we
live our lives nowadays we know the body
is designed to detox
but it was designed you know a long long
time ago and maybe not equipped for the
sort of pollution and the environment
and the lifestyles that we have nowadays
and i think something that can actually
support your body in detoxing and kind
of
kick-start a healthier diet has to be
beneficial
the the benefits of of detoxing are
proven
um i think by and
the customers who tell us they really
feel better they feel them but they
don't do lots of kind of you know
placebo tests with
no don't you don't tend to because at
the end of the day these are nutritional
supplements they're things that you
would also find in food
they're not they're not medicines if
spending money makes you feel better
then go ahead and buy detox products but
i haven't been able to find
any medical evidence which suggests that
you need to so i'm just going to stick
with a glass of water
[Music]
next on the menu the companies find out
who's staying and who's going home
handle my heart chef five
hand on your heart hand on your mate
that's a bit high
i discover what england manages fenn
does the night before a big match
because he's banned the players i'm
having a little bit of nookie before the
game so it must be the same for you
no well and kim charms the diners with
aggies trifles
oh my god kimmy my darling yes
you made the dessert so you're gonna
have to help me serve it now yes okay
great cause you're number one
kid why don't you go actually go to the
table start serving and that way we keep
you out of the kitchen
yeah exactly thank you so much thank you
thank you so much shut your face
aggie's do you feel really happy now
that you're serving your own dessert
here
i never thought that was gonna be
possible you know that i feel so humble
i know it's only a trifle but however
it's a winning trifle
do you know what i am so epic i can't
tell you
at the end of the day i think yours is
better i really do i really mean that
but i am so pleased
they didn't like the salted peanuts well
you know what these plebs are like
come on peanuts unbelievable service
please come on let's go
let's see
my wife does an excellent tribal but
this was really good
and i have to be 100 loyal and say my
wife is better this is my wife's trifle
and it's exceptional of course and she's
been practicing all weekend
[Music]
hi enjoy your dessert usually i don't
need dessert
no i like to prepare make dessert i used
to do it
but i don't need dessert but it was
lovely but it was yours no no
no i lost the challenge today this is
awesome oh this one is so good
yeah oh it's not yours i don't like it
oh thank you um too much alcohol in
there you know that a little bit
well never is enough yeah no honestly no
italian passion coming through it's a
little bit too
easy yeah now and when was the last time
you cooked at home
last night last night and what did you
cook i'm fascinated to find out
uh melancholic parmigiana you know how
to make it
explain i gotta teach you yeah i'd love
you to teach me how to make melons
what the [ __ ] is it oh
oh we're sorry uh
it is hard it's fantastic one of the
best place it's lovely
it's been enjoying it yes yes he does he
enjoys his food doesn't he
yes definitely does yeah you're cooking
or does he prefer eating out no no no
i do yes it helps me i can't imagine
standing in the kitchen standing there
with a penny on
now you is doing well yeah having uh do
you bottom about
it twenty slice that's a lot thinner
i don't know we're working together
we're a team we're talking
what kind of food does he like eating
before a match is it
similar to the players or i never asked
him what he had so you're not with him
the night before
no i'm not no i know we didn't like
before i'm going to change this though
yeah i'll say
rules it must be because he's banned the
players from having a little bit of
nookie before the game so it must be the
same for you
no well you're different players than a
manager but
i was not there that's great
rumor has it you find the kitchen the
sexiest
place in the house the other place
they're too easy
yes and do you have uh wood or granite
or marble what's on your services
uh it's wood so you've got no carpet
burns no it's not okay there's wood on
the floor
but it's wood somewhere isn't there no
you're living in london do you actually
miss
real true classic italian food one thing
if we really were missing and actually
i've ever very good for you it's a
little present for you
it is the lemon chutney yes thank you it
looks very strong whatever it is
sorry i'm going to explain what it is
it looks like olive oil exactly but it's
a limoncello
it's quite dangerous because this is
close to 40
alcohol so it's like a lemon liqueur and
this is your mum's recipe yes
my mother asked me is she just sent over
today that smells amazing you know
so let me know what i want
usually
we gave that to the players last week at
half time against argentina oh my god
is that why they got their act together
finally yes
you're an absolute star now if we give
you a kiss we'll soon be annoyed no
nice to see see you yeah
thank you thank you thank you because i
feel pissed
[Laughter]
it's time for me to tell the comments
who will stay on for the semi-finals
and who will go home right yes abbas
chef yeah well done to you both uh tama
if you could change something today what
would you do
i'd make sure a couple of dishes like
the lettuce was
cooked enough right stop so what have
you done to that so
uh the flame's caught on the pound yeah
well okay well
yeah if his corn is burnt get rid of it
yeah of course you do some more wake up
come on
give yourself a mark out of ten what
would you give yourself four four let's
generous
abbas five five and my heart shift five
hand on your heart hand on your bollocks
mate that's a bit high
look at that there yeah that's clumsy
yeah that's correct next time get it
right
let's start again yeah third time lucky
scallops in the pan
now hello this time i wanna i want you
to really think about how much money
you're wasting
and i want you seriously to wake up and
get a grip the person that i'm going to
be
um sending home is
a bass you're leaving the kitchen
tama you're staying and 4 out of 10 was
high
not bad but masses of room for
improvement yes
and thank you however i don't feel
that you're that passionate about
becoming a great chef
but you did well but you tried very hard
thank you very much i put a smile on
that beard this is like
the world cup for a footballer for me um
yeah it's kind of like that or or the
olympic games for
an athlete that does 100 meters i'm like
an athlete of the kitchen
you